[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about the
Fourier series now in our lecture series
on the Fourier transform and wavelets
which is from chapter 2 of our book
data-driven science and engineering so
I'm going to talk about the Fourier
series which is a way of approximating
arbitrary functions f of X as a sum an
infinite sum of sines and cosines of
increasingly high frequency okay so this
is my function f of X let's say that
it's currently defined from negative PI
to PI so I'm going to define something
that's two pi periodic these two pi
periodic sine and cosine waves and I'm
going to write down the Fourier series
and kind of derive how how you can
approximate f of X using these sines and
cosines ok so I'm just going to write it
down and then we're going to talk about
it so we can represent our function f of
X as a sum from k equals 1 to infinity
of cosines and sines of increasingly
high frequency so I'm going to write
this as a sub K cosine of KX plus B sub
K sine KX where a and B are coefficients
these are called my Fourier coefficients
and then this index started K equals 1
to infinity and so these are my sines
and cosines of period one period to
period three and so on and so forth and
I'm also going to add kind of the zeroth
frequency if I had K equals zero I would
get a constant cosine term here and so I
would having a zero and I'm gonna scale
this by two for reasons you'll see later
okay so I have some constant term plus a
sum of cosines and sines of increasingly
high frequency so as K goes from 1 to 2
all the way up to infinity these cosines
become higher and higher frequency these
sines become higher and higher frequency
and these a K and B K coefficients tell
me how much of each of these signs and
coasts
so I need to add up to recover my
function f okay so the last ingredient
here is how do I actually compute these
coefficients a and B and before I start
I want to I want to point out these
cosine and sine waves are two pi
periodic I've specifically made them so
that this is if I plugged in 2 pi for X
and if K was an integer I would get you
know 2 pi periodic functions in X okay
good so now what we're gonna do is is
walk through how you actually compute
these coefficients a and B so my K
coefficients are going to be given by 1
over pi times the integral from minus PI
to PI my function f of X of f of X times
my cosine KX DX ok and so you'll see
already that this looks a lot like an
inner product between f of X and cosine
KX and that's exactly what this this is
just an inner product of f of X with
that caithe cosine wave ok and similarly
I'm going to write my B sub K is equal
to 1 over pi times the integral from
negative PI to PI of f of X with
multiplied with my sine of KX DX ok good
so what we have here are now an
expansion of F we can approximate f by a
sum of cosines and sines of higher and
higher frequency with coefficients that
are determined by the inner product the
the Hilbert space inner product of my
function f with that particular cosine
so the caithe coefficient is my inner
product of F with the case cosine wave
and similarly for BK's and sine case
okay and I'll write this out explicitly
here this is maybe I'll write it right
here this
is the inner product of f of X with my
case cosine function cosine KX
normalized by the magnitude of this
cosine function okay so this is
normalized by 1 over the norm of cosine
KX squared ok so that that's a really
important thing to do is when I project
f into this cosine K direction I'm
talking in vector vector speak now I
need to normalize by the length of this
function and that the norm of this
function is given by 1 over norm of
cosine KX squared you could compute this
by taking the inner product of cosine KX
with itself and squaring it ok or sorry
that just the inner product of cosine KX
with itself that is the norm squared
good and similarly for the the BK this
can be written as 1 over sine KX norm
squared times the inner product of f of
X sine KX ok good so what we've done
here is we have written these
coefficients a and B in terms of inner
products with my function f and that
particular frequency cosine and sine
wave and again we're normalizing by the
length by the length of those functions
the norms of those functions squared
which happened to be 1 over PI in this
case okay good so there's kind of a
geometric picture that goes along with
this that I think I want to show you
because I think this is super important
to build your intuition for what we're
doing here so what we have in our F
expression is some come of a k's times
cosine KX is plus b ches times sine of K
X's okay and I told you that these
coefficients a K and B K are just my
function projected on to that particular
cosine and sine wave okay and so what I
want to draw here now this is how I
think about these Fourier see
so let's say I have two sets of two
orthogonal basis for a 2-dimensional
vector space so let's say I have this
little X unit direction and my little Y
unit direction here and let's say I have
a completely different orthogonal basis
given by U and V ok and if I have some
test vector F in this vector space let's
say I have some test vector F I can
represent F in either my XY coordinate
system or my UV coordinate system okay
and the way I would do that is quite
simple if I want to represent F in my XY
coordinate systems I take the projection
of F in the X direction that's literally
given by the inner product of F with X
so I'm going to write this out we have F
and I'm going to write it in blue ok so
f hat is equal to the inner product of F
with my little X unit direction in the
unit direction of X plus I do the same
thing i project F in the Y direction ok
plus the projection of F in my y
coordinate Direction times my little Y
unit vector now if this was not a unit
vector X and this was not a unit vector
Y I would have to divide by the norm of
x squared and I'd have to divide by the
norm of Y squared ok now I can do the
exact same thing in U and V coordinates
I could equally well approximate this
function I could say that this is also
equal to F projected into the U
Direction that's the inner product of F
with you it tells me how much of F
points in the U Direction plus the inner
product of F with V in the V Direction
ok this is U bar divided by norm of U
squared plus the inner product of F with
the
in the V Direction norm of V squared
okay so what am I doing this for I'm
trying to convince you that the Fourier
series definition here is exactly the
same as how we write a vector F in an
orthogonal basis in r2 in a two
dimensional vector space I pick some
basis let's say x and y and what I do
the first thing I do is I take the inner
product of F in the X direction then I
take the inner product of F in the Y
direction and I take those coefficients
let's call these kind of a 1 and a 2 I
take those coefficients and I multiply
them by the X unit vector and the Y unit
vector and I add them up that's exactly
what we're doing in our Fourier series
here okay
so let's walk through this one last time
we have our function f and we're gonna
say that it is a sum of coefficients
that are just the projection of F in
that function direction in this basis
Direction times that basis vector so
this is kind of the meaning of the
Fourier series is that my sines and
cosines are orthogonal functions just
like x and y are orthogonal vectors and
I can take my function f and I can
project I can figure out how much of f
is in this cosine direction
that's my a case coefficient and I
multiply that by that cosine function
and I add all of those up okay so I want
you to think about this this takes a
little while to sink in but the Fourier
series is literally just how to write F
in an orthogonal basis of sines and
cosines exactly how we're used to
writing or vectors in orthogonal basis
okay now the last thing I want to point
out is that this is particularly useful
for approximation this is an equality
this is an exact equality I can
represent this function f through this
infinite sum but in practice I might
only want to keep some of these elements
I might only sum from k equals 1 to 10 I
might only keep the first ten sines and
cosines in this case I only took the
first three and I would hope that I get
a pretty good approximation to my
function and that's actually why the
Fourier series is so
useful is because if I truncate this
Fourier series if I say approximately
equal and I get rid of my infinity and I
just say ten then I get a pretty good
function approximation through a
truncated Fourier series okay and that's
something we're going to talk about
we're going to work out some examples in
MATLAB and Python to show how you would
approximate functions using Fourier
series okay so key concepts you can
represent these functions f in terms of
a sum of sines and cosines of increasing
frequency the coefficients a K and B K
can be computed easily numerically using
these integrals and there's a very clean
interpretation of what these
coefficients are these coefficients are
literally how much inner product F has
in that cosine direction and how much
inner product F has in that sine
direction which essentially means that
we're figuring out how much F is
pointing in each of these orthogonal
function directions
okay so we'll talk about this more next
time and we will code this up
also alright thank you